هذا مخالف تمامًا للطائرة
بدون طيار التي تخضع لسلسلة حرفيًا لماذا
يريد شخص ما في العالم الاحتفاظ
بطائرة بدون طيار إذا كان الغرض بأكمله هو الطيران
بعيدًا عن تطبيق كبل رئيسي
سيكون أمان الملف الشخصي على
المراقبة ، على سبيل المثال إذا كنت تعرف
ما إذا كنت  ترغب في الاعتناء بملعب أو
أحداث كبيرة أو تمكنت إدارة الحشود
من إبقائه متدحرجًا في الهواء
لساعات فقط يمنحك طول العمر الذي تعرفه
دون الحاجة إلى الاستمرار في الهبوط
كل 25 دقيقة لتغيير
البطارية ويمنحك فقط
أعيننا في السماء
سيناريو يكون فيه ذلك مفيدًا ،
ربما نشوب حريق كبير أو انهيار مبنى ،
شيء ما يمثل
حادثًا ثابتًا يشرح بالضبط كيف يعمل هذا النظام ،
لذا فإن النظام الذي لدينا هنا هو
الحالة اليومية للمحطة التي قمنا
بتوصيلها بالطائرة بدون طيار  حسنًا ، سيوصل الحبل
إلى الوحدة وستوفر المحطة
طاقة غير محدودة للطائرة بدون طيار ، بحيث يتم
لف كل هذا السلك أو فكه
اعتمادًا على كيفية عمل الطائرة بدون طيار
حسنًا ، حسنًا ، يصل طول البيانات إلى 100 متر ، هذا
هو مصدر الطاقة العادي ، نعم عشرة ياردات ،
لذا فهو حقًا مجرد سلك تمديد كبير
يعتمد بالضبط على المفصل ، ولكن يمكن أيضًا
أن يوفر الحبل البيانات من
الكاميرا ويمكننا جمعها من
المحطة بخير